why do I look like a zombie vampire love
child who sounds like he's losing his
voice because I have the worst seasonal
allergies of any human being I've ever
met in my life and yes it does suck ass
however I might be fitting to review a
vampire movie so let's do that
[Music]
Fright Night alright suppose some of you
or all of you may know I'm a big fan of
vampire movies so when I saw the trailer
to this movie I was like alright we'll
see when I saw Colin Farrell as the
vampire in this movie I was like he
looks like he'll be good
so Fright Nights the story of Anton
Yelchin who lives in the suburbs next to
his new neighbor named Jerry played by
Colin Farrell and Anton Yelchin friend
McLovin Zell I really hate to be the one
to tell you this but that guy your
neighbour Jerry you know he's a vampire
that is a terrible vampire Jerry and it
doesn't take long for Anton y'all can
actually figure out yeah I make Lovins
right Jerry is actually a vampire and
after that the two were just a Dodds
know as I said Colin Farrell was really
good as a vampire that's funny about the
guy cuz he was rising and stardom and he
just went on a coke binge and went away
but now he's back as Jerry the vampire
he was just perfect I was like you know
the good-looking charming vampire
neighbor who is just evil your mom
neglect gives off his scent your girl
she's ripe and when it comes to vampire
movies I'm always like alright do they
have the rules in place can they not
come into your house unless you invite
em what about crosses steaks sunlight
and this movie is old-school vampire
Lauren I like that sunlight burns them
steaks would kill them you can't come
into your house unless you invite him so
it was really cool to see all that stuff
and David Tennant's in the movie knee
pretty much plays the exact character
you think he's gonna play when I saw his
character I was like oh he's gonna be
this character now and by the end of the
movie he's gonna be that character and
that's exactly what happened but doesn't
mean he wasn't awesome he was great he
was like the best part other than Jerry
the vampire Fright Night it's kind of
like if the movie Lost Boys had a
lovechild with rear-window
that's pretty much Fright Night so I
would say if you're a vampire fan you're
looking for a vampire movie that's just
old-school vampire lore and does
vampires justice Fright Night dude it's
a good time no alcohol required I would
say the only thing bad about the movie
is the timing it should come out in
Halloween but if it came out in
Halloween he gets stumped by paranormal
activity but if it came out in the
beginning of summer so it'd be out on
blu-ray by the time Halloween comes out
it gets stomped by all the other summer
movies so it comes out in August to
early for Halloween too late to come out
on blu-ray
by the time Halloween comes out for
Fright Night but it's a good vampire
movie go see it it does vamps justice so
who is your favorite vampire character
of any vampire movie ever comment below
let me know who it is and as always if
you liked what you've seen here and you
want to see more or if you think my
voice is awesomely raspy and sexy click
right here to see more
[Music]
you